- [Voiceover] Hi grammarians.
Today I want to talk about
this idea, in English,
that we call agreement.
So, I'm going to teach
you how to be agreeable,
make it so that all of your
sentences get along really well.
Let me give you an example.
"The dog barks,"
as opposed to,
"The dogs bark."
Do you see the difference?
It's funny because the 's' seems
to migrate, seems to move
from one part of the sentence
to the other.
So what you wouldn't say is,
"The dog bark."
That doesn't work.
And you wouldn't say,
"The dogs barks."
I know that seems strange
that you wouldn't want to have the 's'
follow the other 's',
but you actually only
want to have one of these
in a sentence.
So, "The dog barks."
"The dogs bark."
When there's only one
of something, strangely,
in the present tense, it takes this 's'.
So, "Jake bakes a cake."
"We bake a cake."
Not, "Jake bake a cake,"
which, admittedly, is
a fun sentence to say.
But this is not, in standard
English, this is not correct.
It doesn't exhibit what we call agreement.
Similarly, you also wouldn't say,
"We bakes a cake."
If you're familiar with
the Lord of the Rings books
or movies, if you remember Gollum,
the character Gollum is a
weird little bug-eyed critter
whose just kind of
obsessed with the one ring,
and he has this very
particular way of speaking
that is not, strictly speaking, standard.
He's just wild about that ring.
And the way he refers to everything,
he just throws on an 's' on the end
of every word he uses, every verb.
So, if he's talking about, you know,
this magic ring that he's very fond of,
which he calls the precious,
he wouldn't just say, "I love it."
He'd say, "I loves it."
Like so, and that's not correct.
That does not show agreement.
So, the test here is really...
You can figure out whether or not
you are using agreement in your sentences
if you sound like Gollum.
Because if Gollum were being grammatical,
he would say, "I love it."
So this is the sense that
I want you to develop
is you listen to yourself
speak and you ask,
"Do I sound like Gollum,
the little ring monster?"
Because if you do sound like Gollum,
then you're probably not operating
under the agreement rules
of standard American English,
or you're just doing a Gollum impression.
That's the basic idea behind agreement
Is you just want to make sure
that the parts of the sentence match up.
Sentence parts
match.
They agree.
They get along.
They work.
You can learn anything.
David out.